Tengo curiosidad de qué nos va a dar
la suma de un número racional...
racional...
ok,
si lo sumamos...
si lo sumamos con un número irracional,
vamos a sumarlo con un número...
irracional...
¿Qué vamos a obtener
de la suma de estos dos?
Y bueno, como todavía
no sabemos el resultado,
¿qué te parece si suponemos que la suma
de estos dos nos da...
nos da un número racional?
Vamos a ver a donde llegamos, si pensamos
que nos da un número... racional.
Ok, si esto fuera cierto,
entonces lo podríamos ver de la siguiente manera.
Que un número racional y voy a suponer que
este número se llama "a" entre "b"...
"a" entre "b", ok,
si a "a" entre "b" le sumo
un número irracional...
y como los números irracionales son muy largos,
le voy a poner mejor el nombre de "x",
"x" va a ser mi número irracional...
mi número irracional le voy a poner,
lo voy a bautizar con el nombre de "x",
"a" entre "b" más "x",
esto quiero que me dé un número racional
y a este número racional le voy
a poner el nombre de "m" entre "n"...
"m" entre "n", ok.
Si esto fuera cierto, entonces de aquí puedo despejar
a mi número irracional
y se me ocurre
despejarlo para que lo veas, de la siguiente manera,
"x" es exactamente lo mismo
que "m" entre "n"...
"m" entre "n"
y a esto le voy a quitar,
le voy a quitar éste de aquí,
es decir,
esencialmente lo que estoy
haciendo es restar "a" entre "b"
de ambos lados de esta igualdad,
entonces a esto le voy a quitar
"a" sobre "b".
Ahora, date cuenta que esta operación si
la podemos realizar,
esto es exactamente lo mismo que...
y voy a encontrar un denominador común,
mi denominador común
voy a decir que es "n" por "b"...
"n" por "b", ok...
Y bueno, ¿cómo puedo expresar a "m" entre "n"
con este denominador de "n" por "b"?
Bueno, realmente lo que tenemos que hacer
es multiplicar tanto arriba como abajo por "b",
entonces voy a multiplicar arriba por "b",
abajo por "b",
de tal manera que ya tengo
mismo denominador, el denominador común
y arriba me quedó "m" por "b",
entonces aquí voy a poner...
déjame cambiar de color...
"m"...
"m" por "b"...
por "b", ok.
Y a esto le quiero quitar...
le quiero quitar...
y bueno, ¿ahora cómo podemos
representar a "a" entre "b"
con un mismo denominador,
con nuestro denominador común?
Bueno, para esto
lo que nos hace falta es la "n"
y lo que voy a hacer es multiplicar
tanto arriba como abajo por "n",
"a" por "n"
y "b" por "n"
de tal manera que tengo "b" por "n",
que es lo mismo que "nb"
y arriba me queda "a" que multiplica a "n"...
y lo voy a poner con este color...
que multiplica a "n", ok...
es decir que "x" es igual a "mb" menos "an"
entre "nb".
Ahora, quiero que
te des cuenta de lo siguiente,
en la parte de abajo tengo la multiplicación
de un número entero por un número entero,
como estos dos son números racionales,
tanto  "a" como "b", como "m" como "n"
son enteros
y la multiplicación de un entero por un entero
me da un número entero...
entero, de lujo.
Ahora, vamos a fijarnos
en la parte de arriba,
en la parte de arriba tengo aquí la multiplicación
de dos números enteros, lo cual por cierto
es un número entero...
entero
y a esto le voy a quitar
una multiplicación
de dos números enteros,
lo cual por cierto
es un número entero.
Ok
¿y qué pasa si yo tengo a un entero
y le quito un número entero?
Pues me va a dar un número entero,
estoy diciendo que estos dos...
estos dos...
la resta de estos dos
me va a dar un número entero...
entero, es decir,
esencialmente me estoy tomando
la división de un número entero
entre un número entero.
Vamos a ponerlo aquí,
esto es lo mismo que un entero...
entero, ok,
"mb" menos "an"
es un número entero...
¡Oh que fea "e"!
Un número entero, ok
y a esto lo estoy dividiendo
entre "n" por "b", lo cual también es un número entero...
entero,
ahora si esto pasa,
esto quiere decir
que este número de aquí,
un entero entre un entero
es un número racional...
éste de aquí es un número racional,
que por cierto era el valor de "x"...
era el valor de "x", entonces "x"
debería de ser un número racional...
déjame ponerlo con este color...
"x" debería ser...
debería
ser
racional...
racional,
porque obtuvimos un número racional.
"x" debería de ser racional,
pero nosotros
habíamos dicho que "x" era irracional
y aquí está la contradicción.
Si nosotros suponemos que un racional
más un irracional
nos da un número racional,
entonces llegamos a una contradicción,
una contradicción, esto no puede ser cierto
y esto no puede ser cierto
porque "x" no puede ser
racional e irracional al mismo tiempo.
"x" por una parte
me dice que debe ser irracional
y por otra parte me dice que debe ser racional
y esto no puede ser cierto.
Por lo tanto, esta expresión total
no puede ser cierta...
esto no puede ser cierto, que la suma de un
racional más un irracional me dé un racional
porque llegamos a una contradicción, es decir,
que si nosotros queremos escribir bien la
suma de un racional
más un irracional,
nos debe de dar
un número irracional forzosamente.
Déjame borrar la pantalla
para poner nuestra conclusión,
vamos a quitar esto de aquí
y vamos a poner una nueva pantalla
y vamos a poner justo aquí
la conclusión a la que llegamos.
Si nosotros tenemos un racional...
un racional...
y a éste le sumamos...
le sumamos
un número irracional...
déjame ponerlo con este color...
le sumamos un número,
irracional...
irracional,
ya sabemos a que llegamos,
la suma de un racional, con un irracional nos
da un número irracional...
nos da un número irracional...
que es justo la conclusión de este video...
esto es muy importante que lo tengas en cuenta.
Hasta la próxima.